- Містере Джонсон, ви стверджуєте, що джерелом цієї речовини,
"Новачок", була Росія. Як вам вдалося так швидко це встановити?
Ми провели розслідування так швидко, як змогли.
Дозвольте мені сказати вам із усією ясністю:
Коли майже два роки тому я став міністром закордонних справ,
однією з моїх цілей було простягнути Росії руку.
І я справді зробив це, коли вирушив у гості
до Сергія Лаврова, до Москви - усупереч порадам деяких людей,
які, до речі, казали мені, що це абсолютно марна справа.
Але я хотів спробувати, тому що, знаєте, я щиро вважаю, що Росія -
неймовірна країна, фантастичне місце, і мені боляче бачити, які відносини склались між нами.
Тож мене по-спавжньому засмутило те, що сталося.
Але коли я подивився на докази, я маю на увазі висновки фахівців з лабораторії "Портон Даун"….
В них є зразки?
Так, і вони у своїх висновках були абсолютно категоричні.
Я запитав відповідального: ви впевнені?
І він відповів, що сумнівів немає. Однак я повинен сказати,
що різниця між сьогоденням і тим, що трапилося 12 років тому з Олександром Литвиненком,
полягає в тому, що ми отримуємо набагато більше знаків солідарності
з боку міжнародного співтовариства, набагато більше розуміння тієї поведінки,
якою вирізняється Росія в останні роки.
Британський уряд і прем'єр-міністерка країни оголосили про вжиття низки заходів.
Ви вислали 23 російських дипломатів. Ви отримали симетричну відповідь.
Яких іщезаходівви збираєтеся вжити? По яких цілях?
Я розумію, що низка заходів будуть непублічними.
Ви повинні розуміти: ми не хочемо цього робити,
ми не отримуємо від цього жодного задоволення.
Я не кажу про задоволення.
Я питаю про обмежувальні заходи.
Ми вислали з країни 23 дипломатів - імовірно, це були шпигуни під дипломатичним захистом.
Є низкаінших дій, до яких ми вдамося,
зокрема посилимо контроль над нашими кордонами.
У нас є маса законів, які дозволяють нам жорстко обходитися з грошима, які були отримані ...
-…незрозумілого походження.
Так, закон про кримінальні фінанси.
Це гроші, отримані незаконним або корупційним шляхом.
Все це ми можемо зробити.У нас є Національне агентство з кримінальних справ.
Воно, може, і візьметься за цю роботу.Але я повинен наголосити, що
Великобританія - країна з верховенством права, і я не можу як політик сказати:
ось займіться грошима цієї людини, зробіть те, зробіть це.
У нас не так все працює.
Як ви гадаєте, країни Заходу можуть піти на радикальні заходи і, наприклад,
спробувати виключити Росію з Ради Безпеки ООН або запровадити нові санкції?
Чому ви смієтеся?
Ну, тому що для зміни складу Радбезу ООН необхідне одноголосне рішення
самого Радбезу ООН, а я не думаю, що Росія так проголосує.
Те, чого ми хочемо, - це працювати з нашими друзями і партнерами,
ділитися розвідданими, зміцнювати нашу оборону від дезінформації і кібератак,
знаходити гроші, як ми говорили, і переслідувати людей, які
незаконним шляхом нажили свої статки. Ось якою буде наша робота.
Наша мета в тому, щоб спробувати показати, що
нам зовсім небайдужа руйнівна, небезпечна, безвідповідальна поведінка з боку Росії,
яка не рахується з людськими життями.
І ми хочемо чинити тиск на цей політичний режим
з тим, щоб він шукав нових шляхів.
І такі шляхи можна знайти.